welcome to this concise review of my
hero academia chapter 234 the chapter
picks up immediately after that
bombshell in Chapter 233 in which read
district rushing Iraqis left-hand which
at the time led me to theorize that
probably decay wouldn't work on his
laughs not anymore given there he nears
or five fingers
we just real quickly tell sugar Aki
about a book he read as a child called
together with our quacks which states
not to judge other people by their power
he then goes on to say that he disagrees
with that notion and that in his opinion
the power you have is directly linked to
your personality as a consequence of
this conclusion he basically says that
Suga Rocky's destructive quirk must mean
that he only lost for destruction and
doesn't seek to create anything which if
we're being honest is probably 100
percent accurate we jestro then crushes
one of the hands the sugar Aki wears on
his person the specific when he crushes
belonging to suga Rocky's dead sister
Hannah this event triggers a series of
blasts flashbacks for sugar Aki in the
first fight back all-4-one is seen
telling shigaraki to wear the hands of
his dead family so that the anger and
fear he has at that moment never goes
away the logic being that the hands will
serve as a constant reminder of the
emotions he has at that moment so in the
next flashback we see sugar aki sister
who in my opinion looks a lot like
almighty master Nana shimmer which I
guess makes sense considering that that
is their grandmother so she confessed
sugar Aki who has just been told of by
his father and then she proceeds to
basically hold his bare hand with all
five of her fingers which indicates
obviously that his quake had his quirk
has an woke another time so sugar Aki
remarks that she's been the only person
to do this at this point present-day
sugar Aarti basically begins to lose it
and it his words the memories are
basically boiling up and his brain is
spinning at this point his eyes begin to
run to the back of his skull Azra destro
continues to crush saga Rocky's left
hand sugar Aki says that quote all of my
missing memories are fitting together
then probably the craziest thing that
happened in this chapter sugar rock he's
crushed hand only has two fingers on it
begins to decay Reed estrous thumb so at
this point we gesture is visibly shocked
as most of us are the reason being
obviously that Suga Rocky's Krug doesn't
work unless he touches something with
all five fingers so this is yet another
upgrade to Iraqis quirk that has
occurred during this arc obviously in
addition to when he decayed a group of
people without touching them and also if
I remember correctly we need to cave the
ground with his feet briefly kind of
remember if I imagine that actually
happened but yeah
so once suga Rocky's two fingers begin
to decay Reed Esther his hand
and get another flashback in this
flashback we see sugar out his mother
beginning to worry and she says that
there's something wrong occurring I
should go out his eyes and she tells it
not to scratch you or it will make it
itch this is most likely is quite
beginning to manifest the sugar rapidly
we know today is very dry and crusty
eyes especially dark circles around
there so it's most likely that beginning
to look up read estro then recalls that
there are cases in which quartz can grow
rapidly due to what he caused an
inadvertent trigger and then he goes on
to say the sugar aki must be on the
verge of an awakening we know that this
trigger was seemingly the never-ending
battle with giganto macchia which has
vastly improved the cause of everyone
involved including obviously toga and
twice from previous chapters we d'etre
then wonders if sugar Rocky's been
training has quotes he would never have
been able to master these movements
without brushing shoulders with death in
a brutal environment every single day
read estra then uses his stress quirk to
power up and definitely become
significantly more monster looking and
he unleashes a brutal smashing shigaraki
which sends him flying straight through
several houses as well as all the hands
flying off his body you know the hands
that belong to his family members this
trick is yet another flashback Meshuga
rocky sees his grandpa giving him his
favorite food which happens to be sweet
rice balls and his grandma trying to
cheer him up he remarks that they were
always so kind and caring finally [ __ ]
rocky collapses and says i remember
everything
back then what I really wanted to say
which is quite reminiscent of Deku what
Dekker says about his mother when all
might initially offers him one for all
however in this case it's actually not
followed up with anything unless I
missed it I didn't actually see sugar
aki revealed what he wanted to say back
then i guess he was just thinking it to
himself as a chapter comes to a close
read esther was told by one of his
underlings that an absolute monster is
heading straight towards him the chapter
ends with giganto macchia finally
arriving and basically bulldozing
anything in his way and that is the end
of chapter 234 of my hero academia
some quick observations that i want to
make were just that sugar aki seemed to
genuinely care more about the family's
hands his family's hands that were being
destroyed rather than his own hand i
guess that comes from two factors i
guess the first fact of being that his
power still actually works even though
his hand is destroyed and the second
factor being that obviously those are
the last remnants that he has of his
family and they're triggering these
memories and unlike most things in the
world it actually seems like he cares
about these these pieces of his family
that he wears on him all the time each
one that fell off was triggering a new
memory it clearly shows that he has a
big attachment to them you can't really
blame me there I mean from
the flashbacks his family seemed very
nice very caring pretty normal and they
don't share any of his uh destructive
tendencies that he has in the present
day and I'm pretty sure none of them
despite any quirks actually whether they
be decayed or anything else
his sister holding his hand was
obviously very touching and he's never
experienced anything like that since or
probably will not ever again also
shaking Rocky's clock is not crazy
powerful I mean he can seemingly decay
with any number of fingers which is
quite terrifying to be honest it makes
me wonder how far a quirk can progress
due to training to think this all
occurred just due to the battle with
giganto macchia which admittedly lasted
a very long time but still shook iraqis
quirk has now gotten to the point where
he can probably decay things without
even touching them using not even all
five fingers i mean that's insane
but yeah that's basically everything i
had to say about this review i wanted it
to be quite concise in terms of just a
review of the chapter for people who
couldn't be bothered to read it and I
just gave a few little opinions in there
here and there this is my first video on
this channel so please subscribe if you
want to stay up to date with the latest
videos that I'm putting out I plan to do
more chat reviews in the future probably
some theories and maybe some fact videos
as well but I'll just see how this video
works out and you know if anyone's
really taking a liking to it I probably
will improve in the future I know this
probably wasn't the best video in the
world but like I said I just want to
give a concise review of what happened
in the chapter I think I did that but
I'm let me know if you think there's any
room for feedback I'm always open to
feedback and yeah thank you for watching